翻訳: Tomoyuki Suzuki
校正: Masako Kigami
こんにちは
私は20年前に ここ仙台にある東北大学で
新しい研究室を立ち上げました
私は航空宇宙工学専攻の
若き教員（助教授）となりました
研究室を立ち上げるにあたって
学生のやる気を引き出すため
研究の目標を設定しました
それは「宇宙への飛行という夢の実現」です
「夢」と言いますと
私のバックグランドはロボット工学なので
具体的には私たちの夢とは
未知の領域を探検する
ロボットを開発することです
何を飛ばすにしても ロケットが必要です
そこで私たちはアメリカに行き
我々の実験装置を打ち上げるために
アマチュアのロケット愛好家たちと
共同作業チームを立ち上げました
この日米共同作業プロジェクトは
ARLISSと名付けられました
学生による人工衛星打ち上げ
国際プロジェクトという意味です
打ち上げ場所はネバダ州にある
ブラック・ロック砂漠です
ロケットは高度4000メートルまで
上昇しますが
これはまだ大気圏外には達しません
しかし このプロジェクトは
学生たちにとって
宇宙システム開発の本物の過程を
学ぶ上でユニークな機会となります
搭載する実験装置は
このプロジェクトの場合 標準的には
350mLのソーダ缶程度の大きさです
ですからこのプロジェクトは「CANSAT」
(缶衛星)と呼ばれます
これは打ち上げと パラシュートを使った
降下の様子を映した写真です
CANSATプロジェクトは1999年に始まり
今では
このアイデアは世界中に広まりました
様々な色のソーダ缶が上空へと
打ち上げられていきました
そして上空で温度と圧力を測定し
写真を撮り 無線でデータを送信します
学生達はこのプロジェクトを通して
多くの貴重なことを学びました
次のステップは本当に
大気圏外まで飛ばすことです
宇宙飛行においては
一辺が10㎝の立方体で
重さ１kgのフォーマットが提案されました
今では これをCubeSatと呼んでいます
東北大学の私の研究室の学生たちは
カメラを搭載した
やや大型のCubeSatを開発しました
そしてとても稀な機会を得ることができました
国際宇宙ステーションから
日本人宇宙飛行士によって
宇宙空間へと放出されました！
これが地球の映像です
写真にとても小さな箱型衛星が
写っているのがお分かりになりますか？
これが学生によって作成された衛星なのです
これはCubeSat RAIKO(雷鼓)によって
撮影されたものです
私の最初の夢が叶った瞬間です
学生が作った衛星が宇宙の場で
写真を撮影し
データを地上局に送信することが
できたのです！
しかし我々の夢はどこまでも続きます
私たちは 科学的な
リモートセンシング（地球観測）の能力をもった
より大きな衛星の開発に取り組みました
新たな目標に向かって
学生達は一生懸命に取り組み
素晴らしい結果を残しました
新らしい衛星は50㎝角の物です
重量は50kg
このタイプは MicroSat（マイクロサット）と呼ばれます
第一号機はRISING(雷神)です
５年後にはRISING-2も完成しました
さて 問題はこれらの衛星をどうやって
宇宙空間へ運ぶか？
答えは 相乗り（ピギーバック）打上げです
日本の宇宙開発機関である
JAXA(宇宙航空研究開発機構)は
小型衛星に対して相乗り打上げの機会を
提供してくれています
これがGOSAT
JAXAの大型衛星で
1000kg以上の重量があり
開発費も数百億円です
我々のマイクロ衛星がいかに小さいか
お分かりになるでしょう
全体から見れば小さなおまけかもしれませんが
我々にとっては素晴らしい機会です
2009年1月のRISING-1の打ち上げは
素晴らしいものでした
そして2014年5月にはRISING-2が
続きました
どちらの衛星も今軌道上を周回しています
特にRISING-2は見事な成果を出しています
これは搭載された広角カメラで撮影した
地球の映像です
画像の質はとても向上しています
大型台風の映像も撮影されました
これは比較したもので
右側はRISING-2で撮影したもの
左側は日本の気象衛星で
撮影されたものです
大学の学生が作った衛星が
プロによる大型衛星に
負けない成果をあげているのです
RISING-2にはカラーの望遠カメラも
搭載しています
日本の街、家や水田の風景を
拡大したものです
解像度は５mで
このクラスの衛星では
世界最高の性能です
とても素晴らしく 喜ばしいことです
私たちのマイクロサットへの挑戦は
人工衛星を
小さく、安く、早く作ることに成功しました
コストについていえば
100分の１にすることができました
低コストでありながら 得られる画像は
地球観測に十分なものです
１つの衛星では地球のほんの一部しか
カバーできません
でも もしも100億円の予算があれば
１基の高価な大型衛星ではなく
48基のマイクロ衛星を打ち上げることを
提案します
これで地球全体を連続的絶え間なく
隙間なくカバーできます
このようにして地球を
24時間体制でモニターし
例えば災害監視のネットワークを
築くことができます
なおも我々の夢は終わりません
ネバダの砂漠に戻りましょう
CANSATプロジェクトが成功したのち
別のアイデアが浮かびました
学生によるマイクロ探査車のコンペです
ロケットで打ち上げた後
自力で帰還できるような
ロボットを作るよう学生に指示しました
ロボットは
パラフォイル型の翼で飛行しても良いし
着陸後に地表を進んでも構いません
私の学生たちは
２輪のロボットを設計しました
筒型をしたロケットの形状に
フィットするからです
重量はCubeSatと同じくわずか１キロです
車輪の間にはバッテリー、コンピューター、
センサーとモーターが搭載されています
自律走行に必要な 全てを備えています
毎年新しい学生が研究室に加わると
彼らに新しいロボット探査車を作るように
指示します
そして数年後には
設計はより精緻なものになっていきました
このビデオクリップは
2008年の学生コンペの時の物です
見事な打ち上げと － そしてパラシュート
着陸後にロボットは陸上では不要な
パラシュートを
自力で切り離します
そして地上を動き始めます
その速度はとても速いのですよ！
GPSの座標データを参照して
ロボットはゴールへと向かっていきます
しかし地表は決して生易しいものでは
ありません
自力で困難な状況から脱出し
ついにはゴールに辿りつくことが出来
皆とても興奮しました
これは７年がかりの学生プロジェクトの
進化の成果です
今日はこの舞台で探査ロボット(ローバー）の
最新モデルを「Tetris」を
お見せすることができて大変光栄です
さあ こちらへ
とてもかわいらしく
素敵にデザインされています
これは日本の砂丘で行った
Tetrisの１つ前のバージョンの
フィールド試験のビデオです
カメラが搭載されており
とても興奮する映像です！
次の夢はこのロボットを月の表面に
運ぶことです
動機は「Google Lunar XPrize」です
これはグーグルがスポンサーとなっている
世界大会で
懸賞金総額は約30億円です
その要件は
非政府の団体が
月までロボットを送り込み
月面を500m以上走行し
そして高画質の映像を送信することです
ルールは単純ですが
達成は容易ではありません
今日のところ 様々な国から18のチームが
競い合っています
日本からも１チーム参加し
この挑戦し甲斐のある競争で
先頭グループにいることを
とても誇らしく思います
そのチームは「ハクト」！
ハクトは月に住む白ウサギのことです
日本語では「しろうさぎ」と言います
チーム・ハクトは最近
打ち上げ準備が整ったことを
実証するための
２つのモデルを公表しました
1つには「Moonraker」のニックネームが
付けられました　もう一方は「Tetris」です
とても小さな探査車ですが
素晴らしい能力を秘めています
このTetrisはわずか２kgですが
この小さな機体に
最新技術が詰め込まれています
例えば車輪は３Dプリンターで製造された
超強度プラスチックでできています
この２つの探査車をロープでつなげて
操縦します
XPrizeのルールでは
走行する場所は自由です
しかし我々はたいへん興味深い目的地を
考えています　洞穴です
2007年 日本の月面探査衛星
「かぐや」は
月面にある小さな縦孔を発見しました
科学者たちは 月面の地下にある
溶岩トンネルへの
入口か 天窓のようなものと考えています
自然のトンネルや 洞穴は
将来 人類が居住するために
都合の良い場所です
温度環境がマイルドであり また
放射線や隕石の衝突から
保護できるからです
洞穴探検を実現するアイデアは
単純なものです
穴の縁で 大型の探査車が
アンカーの役となって居座り
小型の探査車 つまりTetrisが
穴を降りていきます
このビデオは概念を示しています
これは小さな崖で試したものですが
もっと深く 切り立った穴でも
上手くいくことでしょう
地下の探査が終わったら
このちいさな探査車はロープで
引っ張り上げられます
このようにXPrizeは非政府団体が
技術革新と新たなビジネスに
挑戦することを促進しています
宇宙開発プログラムは
一部のエリートに限られることなく
誰もが参加できるよう
開かれたものであるべきです
オープンな競争は古い宇宙ビジネスの
有り方をきっと変えることでしょう
実際のところ 今もなお
宇宙開発プログラムは 大型で
とても金がかかり 進歩が遅く
他人を寄せつけず
まるで恐竜のようであります。
しかしマイクロサットとマイクロローバーが
状況を変えることでしょう
小型で 低コスト かつ
素早い宇宙開発を実現するアイディアは
たくさんあります
最も大切なことは
宇宙開発に対する敷居を下げ
参加できる人を増やすことです
特に若い人々を参加させることが重要です
宇宙はとても身近な所まできています
手作りの衛星と手作りのローバーが
それを可能にしてくれます
皆さんも参加して下さい
一緒に興奮を味わいましょう
どうも有り難うございました
(拍手)